[Music]
there's just so much going on and not
only that like inside there's a lot
going on so I just feel like I'm on this
roller coaster of emotions and I feel
like I'm gonna explode it's just all too
much for me Nikki Bella seemed to be
stressed long before her and John Cena
split
in a total Bellis clips film before
their breakup the couple is preparing
for their engagement party and the
bride-to-be's nerves are getting the
best of her the engagement party is here
but I feel so overwhelmed I honestly
feel like I'm about to have an anxiety
attack at one point John even tells an
emotional Nikki she can call things off
if wedding planning is becoming too
overwhelming
[Music]
I have two five five to do that did you
maybe let me know once also despite not
getting married on May 5th as planned
Nikki told ET she still has hope for the
couple to reconcile John is such an
amazing man and he really is the love of
my life and I truly hope one day that we
can work it out and get back together
and I think there is hope and my biggest
thing is I just want to spoon feed live
the rest of our lives happy and
hopefully that's together maybe it's not
[Music]
[Applause]